c'est faisable ce qui n'est pas inutile
pour nous peut être utile pour quelqu'un
d'autre peut-être ça risque pas de
froisser la personne qui vous l'a offert
je pense pas je peux ne pas leur dire
est ce que vous seriez prêt à revendre
sur internet
je leur donne en général chorfi leur
fils en cadeau on voit de plus en plus
de gens qu'ils font est ce que vous ça
vous savoure tout pas benon non il faut
me stephens t elle il lance un cadeau et
pour la personne qui l'a offert b si
elle le sait pas c'est un cadeau aux
oiseaux savent quelque chose quelqu'un
qui me donne quelque chose sur le gave
près chacun peut mais je le ferai pas
taillé de thebaux pourquoi ça vous sert
de ferment un cadeau c'est reçu de
quelqu'un de proche factuellement
des échanges qu'on aime comme moi je
connais pas trop seul